Hello children, you often ask a question that
how should I remember the formulas, so look at the
formula, now your exams are coming near, so
one way to revise the formula can be that if you have
Ras Agarwal or Rod Sharma book, then
in it you have these  You must have seen that
when any exercise starts, there are some
small questions in it.
If you do those questions quickly then there are
formulas. If you may
not remember the time then you can solve them by
looking at the formulas.  Even if you do those four punch questions
which they give in the beginning of every chapter
in the exercise, then it
can be a very good way to
revise the formula.